bonjour pour cette dernière émission de
l'année 1973 nous vous avons réservé
deux surprises
la première c'est qu'aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau vous ne verrez que des hommes
très exactement 11 au total
et la deuxième qui est une conséquence
de la première c'est nous nous parlerons
que de vous c'est à dire des femmes ou
plutôt de la femme on les fait chaque
être masculin à dans un coin de son
coeur ou de son imagination une
photographie physique et morale ce qu'on
peut appeler la femme idéale et sept
femmes revêt bien sont bien entendu une
multitude d'aspects suivant les goûts
imagination du soupirant et la plupart
d'entre vous tout même correspondent
pour un ou plusieurs hommes à l'image
parfaite cette femme peut-être cette
femme idéale peut être un rêve ou
simplement un rêve mais quelquefois il
peut être aussi la compagne que nous
cherchons et avec laquelle nous
souhaitons faire notre vie
c'est donc de cette femme idéale nous en
parler aujourd'hui nous avons essayé de
la cerner ne nous envoyez pas trop de
vous mettre ainsi sur la sellette
et en plus de ça de donner la parole
simplement à des hommes voulant
reprendre est très vite cette parole dès
le début 1974 avec en plus un acquis
peut-être à la qui le fait de savoir ce
qu'il faut faire ou ce que vous pouvez
faire pour nous plaire encore plus en
1974 la brigade masculine que nous avons
sur ce plateau est composé ainsi ch
un téléspectateur qui s'appelle monsieur
spiga rallye et qui vient de meurthe et
moselle qui rasent dessinateur bien
connu qui est d'ailleurs de sortir un
bouquin qui s'appelle maleev pardon dans
les mots rien entre hommes comme en
parle qui s'appelle parlez moi de moi
chez denoël
le docteur gilberte tolman tordjman qui
est un sexologue qui a lui aussi sorti
un livre qui s'appelle la maladie
conjugales un autre téléspectateurs qui
vient de tourner une suite barnaud et
jacques veyrat qui continue son petit
tour de piste
je remplace aujourd'hui excusez-moi
valérie manuels et des call andré je
présente donc monsieur bardot un ami
téléspectateurs de tourbe dans le var 10
dekker ne pourrait pas faire cette
émission sans guider car le romancier de
la femme
personne ne dira le contraire
un autre téléspectateurs monsieur
jean-claude penney qui habitait herblay
dans le val d'oise près de moi quelqu'un
qui connaît bien le au moins le coeur
des femmes est peut-être davantage
encore jose luis de vilallonga monsieur
jean yves blais téléspectateurs
également de la région parisienne et
enfin monsieur joël quesnel et qui est
un parisien
rassurez vous les femmes ne sont quand
même pas totalement absent de cette
émission puisque vous allez en voir
quelques unes en images
nicole andré en a rencontré certaines et
leur a posé une question comment elle
les femmes voyez la familiale elle
compte à le penser que les hommes
voyez cette familiale c'est un reportage
que nous allons voir tout de suite un
petit reportage de guy labourasse et de
nicole entre voici donc les seules
femmes de cette édition
comment pensez vous que votre mari voit
la femme idéale
je pense qu'il ya une grande femme
blonde bon intelligente simple quand
même et vous même comment la voyez-vous
copia aussi dans le fond puisque c'est
moi qui ai répondu si vous pensez être
ce familiale madame comment pensez vous
que votre mari voit la femme idéale
physiquement et moralement on voit une
épouse à bord dans ce cas nous
respectons et font venir des familles
gentille fort
vous souhaitez une bonne lumière il
donne ménagères tout en restant cook s
imaginent je pense dans mon jour
intelligente cultivée
pourtant paris mon dieu je pense qu'il
abattrait brûle idem il adore les poules
et les favoris d'ailleurs style qu'il
aime d'abord les vallées validé sur
chivu c'est quelque chose qui t'a
toujours passionnés qu'ils fassent ils
dépensent encore et moralement
moralement mon dieu qu'elle soit gay
jolie oui de préférence et intelligente
et éventuellement éventuellement a
certainement bien sûr jany payet pas
toutes simples pas trop fait
c'est moi je ne vois pas la femme idéale
puisque je viens de vous dire qu'il
n'avait pas donc je pense que mon mari
va penser comme moi qui a pas de femme
idéale mais vous même voie et vous même
comment la voyez-vous je l'envoie grande
blonde sportive physiquement une grande
salle du retail normal mètre soixante
dix peut être est il s'oriente surtout
et
ça c'est dans des qualités morales est
certaine la femme idéale si souvent
représentée par la botte par des
mannequins et autres alors on peut aussi
essayer d'identifier d'autres ont
physiquement j'avais assez grande jeune
assez joli moralement ouvrage 300 joue à
la familiale d'une famille premièrement
travail et ils activités
soit indépendante entièrement d'humains
soit passé
et je dois une
famille des as legrand de belles très
coquette mais
j'aimerais bien qu'elle soit un peu
femme de ménage qu'elle se plaît
beaucoup à l'intérieur que sa tribu à
face est bien avec son mari
wasquehaliens sont pas tous par exemple
patti retard qu'elle ne soit pas
toujours appelé lui aussi été aussi tués
ou sur place et toutes les séries d'être
cette femme idéale oui je sais mais j'ai
aussi jalouse alors je serai tout au
moins et compenser toute cette femme
idéale je ne sais pas une femme idéale
m'ont fait je pense que mon mari pendant
deux mois non pas tout à fait comme non
je sais pas prétentieuse est ce que vous
pensez être cette familiale va voir ses
qualités qu'il faut pour
moi je mettais bien comme je suis au nom
je crois pas je suis pas parfait est ce
que vous pensez lettre cette famille des
ailes
pour marie
on sait vous l'être cette familière je
vais aider enfin charité bien ordonnée
commence par moi je pense que la femme
idéale doit être intelligente et
compréhensive pour moi elle représente
sa la femme idéale quand à mon mari bien
c'est un être charmant et nous sommes
mariés depuis 40 ans il est adorable
alors je crois qu'ils voient peut-être
en moi la femme idéale je n'en sais rien
mais je suis garé lille et burbure
partout après que ces dames et de leurs
avis monsieur spiga rallye vous êtes le
plus jeune d'entre nous nous allons vous
donne la parole en premier
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette synthèse féminine
tout d'abord je pense que les fans vont
enfin certaines vous sentirez des ennuis
à coësmes nf ce que dira que la femme
est exclusivement la bonne femme la
bonne mère de famille le fait un cordon
peu c'est un peu restreint je pense pour
le rôle que la femme a joué dans la
société actuelle alors est la vôtre vous
êtes très très intéressé par ce problème
là mais je suis très intéressé 1
familiale pour moi c'est avant tout une
femme qui sait s'adapter à toutes les
situations que toutes les situations
c'est l'expression qui convient
alors pour ma part enfin à 19 ans et
peut-être impression trop franc certains
mais je les trouvais et je suis très
heureux quand ça vous l'avez trouvé où
se trouvait alors elles se regroupent
les mena d'écrire si c'est pas trop
indiscrets physiquement physiquement
moralement au stade du ray normalement
c'est une personne qui s'intéresse à la
vie politique dans le monde entier qui
s'intéresse à tout ce qu'une personne
alors assez pour un peu instituée au
niveau des jeunes qui s'intéressent à la
musique anglaise et surtout qui est très
très jolie mais elle est comme elle est
brune
j'en dirai pas plus parce que ses
parents sa femme idéale pour n'en resta
pas qu ils ont du style homme idéal
pourrait vous avez apporté un petit
poème de verlaine qui correspond à quoi
pour vous je pense que ce sont les
finitions sa définition de la familiale
non parce que je pense pas qu'on puisse
définir vraiment la femme idéale sa part
tient un peu sous les eaux
certes à sion commando nos lycées que
pensez-vous du bonheur que représente le
bonheur pour vous et je pense pas que la
femme dalle puis se défirent mais si on
peut la définir je pense que verlaine la
l'a bien résumé sa définition de résumer
un peu grand saut vers lequel je veux
bien précis je fais souvent ce rêve
étrange et pénétrant d'une femme
inconnue et que j'aime et qui m'aiment
et kinés chaque fois ni tout à fait la
même ni tout à fait une autre et même et
me comprends car elle nous comprend et
mon coeur transparent pour elle seul
hélas cesse d'être un problème pour elle
seule et les moiteurs de montfranc blême
elle seule laisser rafraîchir en
pleurant et l brune blonde ou rousse jeu
lugnorre son nom je me souviens qu'il
est doux et sonores comme ceux d aimé
que la vie exil à son regard est pareil
regard des statuts et pour sa voix
lointaine et calme est grave elle à
l'inflexion des voix chair qui se sont
tus voilà pour moi la familiale la vôtre
ressemble à ça si je comprends bien ça
elle ressembler avant que j'ai là que je
la rencontre puisque je peux vous dire
qu'elle est brute je peux vous dire
c'est la femme que vous avez rencontré
monsieur la femme idéale mais j'ai
l'impression mois que notre avis est
l'homme idéal
je crois que toutes les femmes ont un
homme idéal et que tout le monde tout
homme est l'homme idéal de quelqu'un
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup entendre parler
comme ça parce que c'est
merveilleusement rafraîchissant
d'entendre un homme jeune parler comme
ça
malheureusement dans 40 ans vous
penserez autrement est-ce que vous même
levé rencontré la femme idéale pour moi
la femme idéale c'est toujours la
dernière tant qu elle tient le coup
personnellement je l'éprouvé oui souvent
alors en améliorant le prototype chaque
fois parce qu'on aime toujours l'homme
la même femme on se trompe toujours sur
la même femme et puis un beau jour on
trouve
allez voir qu'à chaque fois vous
améliorez est ce que ça ne faudrait
plutôt que d'expérience en expérience
vous êtes deux mois sont moins exigeants
c'est à dire qu'avec l'âge on arrive à
savoir ce que l'on ne veut plus n'est ce
pas et quand on sait très bien que ce
que l'on veut on le trouve très rarement
il se complaît dans les précisions dans
les précisions que je vous dise qu'on
veut plus qu'on veut bien lui correspond
vous savez il ya des tas de choses
extrêmement ennuyeux chez les femmes
alors il faut trouver la femme qui n'a
pas tout ça n'est ce pas cela mais on se
trompe très très souvent mais c'est quoi
tous nos maux il ya des livres à écrire
là dessus
commençons le soleil pour moi je crois
que le le principal défaut d'une femme
c'est c'est d'être une femme exactement
aïe voilà c'est d'être une femme telles
qu'elles le sont maintenant c'est à dire
des sont très conscientes de leurs
pouvoirs très conscients de leur
importance en même temps ils réclament
extrêmement beaucoup beaucoup de
responsabilités qu'elle n'avait pas
autrefois ils ne veulent plus être des
femmes objets volants godinot zawaj moi
je le regrette infiniment je suis de la
génération des femmes sont obligées tu
crois que votre voisin me suis brûlé pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous à ce qui
se dit non parce que pour moi la la
femme idéale n'est pas un être
exceptionnel
c'est un être vivant elle n'est pas un
bep d'un au rac et qu'on attaque en rêve
et les vivantes et les mêmes plus vivant
que la bâtisse de dante puisque son
pouvoir bénéfique et peut l'exercer de
son vivant et vous permet de tout à
chacun de se dépasser et de donner
soi-même au maximum ensuite je crois que
une de ses qualités principales c'est
qu'elle est très intuitive et qu'elle
permet son mari ou à l'homme qu'elle
connaît de conserver sa réserve intime à
laquelle elle ne touche pas sa qualité
maîtresse sa qualité dominante c'est la
franchise
ses qualités de base avec la franchise
on peut arriver à tous chez une femme
partant de là il n'est pas jalouse sa
confiance elle a donné une fois pour
toutes
est ce qu'elle est nécessairement bel
oiseau ne pas être pas prendre ce
serment belle étant donné que les canons
de la beauté sont très difficiles à
définir
pour moi la femme idéale de toute sa
personne et mana charmeux discret
qu'elle ignore bien que toute occasion
il reste très féminine c'est la femme
d'une vie que vous définissez c'est la
femme d'une vie oui cette femme d'une
vie mais à mon avis cette femme est
également idéal parce qu'il est très
perfectible
là vous retrouver je n'avais jamais cru
pouvoir trouver en tête à tête en
optimist je suis en ce qui concerne ma
femme et je vous fais ici l'idée car
votre corps vous êtes pessimiste je suis
pas pessimiste mais enfin fait beaucoup
de bouquins et mes héroïnes s'appelle un
pur la tricheuse la corruptrice les
filles de joie elle a révolté
avait appelé ces femmes-là la sainte la
petite bourgeoise la femme de ménage
comme nous a dit une dame la dévouée et
même lambert 2
aucune femme ne les aurez lu les hommes
encore moins les aurais aimé moi je suis
pas du tout le temps que la femme idéale
ont pu visionner quelques qualités ils
sont pas du tout celles qu'elle croit
avoir un coût nous croyons certain que
nous sommes optimistes leurs données
pour moi la femme idéale à cette qualité
aa à 7437.65 redford
elle a cette qualité et c'est vrai qu'il
faut les définir rapidement la première
et messieurs je crois sont d'accord ces
messieurs et même des dames qui ont
passé tout à l'heure c'est la beauté
attention par la beauté ne veut pas dire
une beauté permanente par exemple nous
avons des femmes laides qui sont belles
et nous avons des femmes belles qui sont
pas jolis donc la beauté c'est une chose
qui change à travers le temps de la
fraîcheur la jeunesse qui évolue et qui
devient une beauté vieillissante
ce qui est toujours très agréable de
voir une femme qui sait vieillir qui
vieillit bien des on doit dire pour les
femmes actuellement à leur hommage c'est
qu'elles savent vieillira c'est bien ce
qui nous rajeunit nous les hommes elles
ont fait de gros progrès pascoe fois la
femme de 30 ans était une vieille dame
la brute
gilbert qui veut qu ici pour la beauté
tout le monde oui j'ai l'impression de
croire l'agent devant la beauté ce sens
qu en ce sens que je pense effectivement
que le canons esthétiques de la femme
idéale pour chacun est extrêmement
variable et répond à des impressions
infantile que nous ignorons souvent et
qui fait que toute femme a sa chance y
compris
j'ai par exemple j'ai par exemple un de
mes patients qui a épousé
consécutivement teuteu successivement
que le dise à trois reprises une femme
qui louche qui est un strabisme
il est attiré par ce type de femme n'est
ce pas non ceci pour dire que la femme
idéale pour chacun en ce qui concerne
notre esthétique répond à des
impressions infantile très particulières
qui sont extrêmement variables de l'un à
l'autre et qu'on peut définir a priori
voilà pour la bouteille oui je
il a tout à fait raison la première fois
de ma vie que j'étais amoureux
je devais avoir 4 ou 5 ans je me
rappelle c'était une passion terrifiante
c'était une nurse que j'avais quitté la
copie exacte parce que je les retrouver
beaucoup plus tard d'ingrid bergman
c'était une grande femme avec des
énormes pied des énormes mains laver à
grande eau et j'étais amoureux mandingue
de cette femme toute ma vie j'ai aimé
des femmes grandes avec des grandes
mains des grands lapied ces éléments
fait qu'ici tout l'important est que sur
lequel il faudra petit rap peut-être
dire un mot tout à l'heure prenant la
parole à guider car si vous voulez bien
dans mon tous était amoureux non honneur
de nous le gouvernement de lobo niche
des femmes qui nous l'avait qui nous
torche et qui nous fait baisser les
avons aimé elles ont tout fait mais la
deuxième qualité peut-être d'une femme
des gens qui ne sont pas d'accord et
surtout des dames c'est je crois la
luxure parce qu'une femme qui n'a pas
l'adduction onel à mon avis n'est pas
une femme une femme et clément quelque
chose
la troisième phase d'observation sur la
luxure je suis pas d'accord je suis pas
d'accord
non je pense que l'induction n'est pas
indispensable pour la femme il suffit
qu'elle le soit
qu'elle soit attrayante et quelles
qu'elles prouvent un amour sincère sans
être sans faire l'objet de luxure mais
je crois que semble pas très important
que la femme soit la luxure yeux je me
contente de l'être moi pour dire oui
mais par l'udc sur un bardeau par
luxueux que monsieur qui des cassures
internes quoi se rassurer à ce que vous
savez vous permettez et si vous y voyez
à mon avis l'attirance sexuelle c'est à
dire la naissance n'est ce pas la
naissance de l'homme vis-à-vis d'elle je
suis d'accord avec vous je crois je
crois que 1 des canons de la beauté sur
le plan pratique c'est c'est de nous
éveiller l'attirance qui nous éveille
c'est mon point de vue je pense que
c'est une des bases de notre de l'autre
individu alors si la luxure c'est ça
absolument d'accord avec vous je dirais
je dirais aussi je suis d'accord avec
guy des cars pour beaucoup de gens mais
je dise que c'était extrêmement
variables dans la mesure où cela dépend
de la conception que j'en fais deux
constitue le fait de l'amour dans la
mesure vous pensez que c'est l'harmonie
physique qui conditionne l'harmonie du
couple
il est évident que la luxure les cordes
abondante plantureuse joue un rôle si au
contraire et pour beaucoup de gens c'est
comme cela si vous imaginez que c'est
l'harmonie spirituelle qui va
conditionner l'accord sexuelle eh bien
il en est tout autrement et ce sont les
qualités de générosité ou les qualités
morales qui vont prendre le problème pas
sur celle ci mais ce cigare et
l'excellence et la luxure votre âge
non non je suis ni plomb ni quand c'est
à dire qu'il ya des personnes et qui
s'adapte parfaitement à tous est de
savoir mieux la beauté d'une même s'il
n'est pas tombé
sinon la luxure excuses et malentendants
du son et c'est pas une qualité de jeu
nes la luxure vous aimez vous faites
l'amour parce que vous êtes amoureux
vous aimer une femme la luxure le
produit d'une civilisation ces deux
produits d'une expérience est le produit
d'une connaissance le produit de
beaucoup de choses la luxure c'est un
art qui s'acquiert qui s'apprend oui il
ya des gens qui sont doués pour ça il ya
des gens qui ne sont pas fameux mam
sapritch par exemple eh bien je crois
qu'elle est douée pour la luxure au
cinéma exemple les gens qui sont
évidemment doué pour la luxure chapitre
trouve à monsieur de coeur mais moi je
suis une très belle qualité de la femme
c'est l'ambition je ne dis pas leur
gueule parce que l'orgueil était une
forme d'un puissant de tous les êtres
mot femme c'est une forme d'orgueil mais
l'ambition est une chose merveilleuse
une femme ambitieuse arrive fait arriver
souvent son mari son amant
c'est une aide extraordinaire si vous
avez une femme
villalonga nous avons rencontré quelques
femmes d'un autre vie c'est dommage
qu'on n'ait pas rencontré ce qui m'a
toujours beaucoup pour lui c'est quand
vous rencontrez une femme qui est
charmante et qu'elle vous dit tu es
gentil avec moi et cetera voilà bah tu
vois mon rêve c'est d'avoir un petit
commerce qui commercent riche que la
femme ambitieuse elle voudrait un grand
commerce a tout donné mais ça messieurs
ne vouliez pas avec des femmes qui n'ont
pas d'ambition que sa trésorerie et des
déceptions épouvantable c'est exact une
femme ambitieuse
ça vous permet quand même d'arriver à
quelque chose parce que ça vous ça vous
épaule ce s'avoue canalise au moins vous
vous avez un but dans la vie beaucoup
plus positif que lorsque vous êtes seul
moi je sais que je trouve justement avec
ma femme
si j'ai un problème professionnel ou
quel qu'il soit où une réalisation cette
extraordinaire de pouvoir en parler à sa
femme et 200 dire qu'elle est là et
qu'elle a l'ambition pour vous et cette
ambition c'est la réussite du foyer en
fait monsieur yves blais vous dit que la
femme vos forces à vous dépasser enfin
force là bas c'était le serbe est
toujours un homme de se dépasser c'est
ça justement une de ses qualités
je leur disais je leur disais que
l'allemagne est dans la définition de
l'amour c'est deviens ce que tu es et il
est vrai que la femme de la femme peut
permettre à certains hommes de se
réaliser dans son essence dans ses
disponibilités qui l'ignorent lui même
il est évident que là où je suis
d'accord avec avec 10 des cas je pense
que dans la mesure où elle a une
ambition qui lui permet de voir ce que
son époux son conjoint son partenaire
est capable de faire elle va le
propulser
et c'est une chose effectivement
excellente en tout cas en ce qui nous
concerne nous laissa j'apprécie beaucoup
ce que vous venez de dire parce que
soyons francs c'est une des choses que
nous pouvons à peu près le mieux donner
à la femme ne pas devoir notre vie
sociale n'est ce pas il est plus facile
pour nous très certainement de pouvoir
lui dire dix ans après tu vois je suis
arrivée là n'est ce pas dû faire ça t'a
pas plutôt que peut-être
avoir des qualités qu'elle aimerait bien
que nous n'avons pas alors je crois que
la femme ambitieuse et peu à la fois un
moteur très certainement sa
indéniablement mais en plus en plus est
en soi à un but que qui que nous pouvons
sur lequel nous pouvons la satisfait je
m'exprime peut-être pas m'enflammer
qu'on continue aux idées car vous vous
permettez à votre quatrième chapitre la
4e qualité adaptés des messieurs qu'ils
vont pas être d'accord des dames qui
écoute et je trouve ça vaut aujourd'hui
nous sert une fois qu'elles ont des
sommes à la quatrième qualité je la
crois très vrai c'est chez une femme
c'est une sorte de corollaire de
l'ambition c'est le goût de domination
une femme ça va loin une femme qui ne
veut pas dominer mais il y aura la
contrepartie tout à l'heure vous avez
faim qui veut pas dominer n'est pas tout
à fait une femme qu'elle égale de son
mari c'est une femme
or je me méfie des femmes modestes j'ai
même très ennuyeuse tout à l'heure il ya
une dame qui a passé quelques mois je
suis modeste me sauver je ne suis pas la
femme qui vous dit je suis modeste je
n'ai pas d'ambition je ne suis pas joli
non vraiment je sais que je ne suis pas
la femme idéale
de deux choses l'une où elle se fout de
nous mais parallèlement elle venait elle
est persuadée qu'elle est jolie qu'elle
est pas modeste elle le sait mais elle
veut pas nous le dire cette femme non
c'est pas vrai car on peut moins même la
femme la plus moche du mois des tout ça
est l'un son besoin de domination
la preuve nous ont tous connu je me suis
dit des vieilles demoiselles des
bénéfices si on a vu de ces bonnes
femmes qui étaient des tambours majors
dans la vie n'est ce pas on a vu pendant
la guerre les directrices d'afat et tout
ça les militaires toutes ces bonnes
femmes qui conduisaient des ambulances
et tout ça et des régimes je ne citerai
pas des femmes de gêner auto connaissons
qui sont là dedans mais quand même
vraiment se sont elles ce sont des
bonnes femmes si on le
le goût de la domination est pour elle
qu'est ce que c'est que le mal le mal
pour elle ce n'est pas mal qu'elle nous
prennent au départ des pauvres types
voilà c'est bon je crois que qu'il est
vrai que la femme peut avoir une volonté
de puissance fantastique
n'est ce pas peut-être pourquoi penser
un petit peu les siècles de répression
qu'elle a subi mais je dois dire que moi
je suis partisan d'une relation à
égalité parce que quand il arrive qu'une
femme domine vraiment dans son couple et
ça j'en vois un très grand nombre est
bien l'homme prend peur de cette mante
religieuse et il n'est pas possible il
n'est pas possible que l'on puisse être
dominés constamment dans la journée dans
la vie quotidien dans sa relation
commerciale avec 100 avec son mari par
exemple et qu'elle puisse accepter le
soir que son mari deviennent dominant
car vous savez que dans le rapport
sexuel il est nécessaire que l'homme au
moins d'un point de vue de jeu de point
de vue d'un point de vue fantasmatique
d'un ton imaginaire que l'on puisse
dominer et l'homme qui a été dominée
constamment dans la vie quotidienne ne
peut pas de but en blanc redevenir le
hussard cas le souhait qu'elle
souhaiterait qu'il devienne et je crois
qu'il ya un nombre d'échecs considérable
de frigidité et de d'échec sexuelles
sont imputables au fait que la famille
dominante
sonia présentant pas d'accord il va
faire un nom mais comme disait monsieur
des deux car nous avons eu des quelques
expériences numériques et moi je suis
arrivé à la bonheur parfait depuis à peu
près un an je suis marié maintenant
depuis un an avec quelqu'un qui est
d'une extrême violence qui est jaloux
sticky mari est allé aide moi qui
espagnol né en algérie enfin que volcan
et je suis devenu avec un suprême
plaisir et avec vraiment avec une joie
totale l'homme objet et je me dis mais
enfin ils sont forts ces bonnes femmes
qui veulent cesser de défendre mme aubry
a rien de plus merveilleux que d'être
l'objet de quelqu'un c'est à dire le le
but
de tous les soins dont je vais faire une
bêtise mais qui n'ont fait pas ça fais
ci fais ça pour la première fois il ya
quelqu'un qui me guide qui me posent
vous dites que sexuellement il faut que
l'homme domine c'est aussi pour la
première fois quelqu'un qui me donne une
je trouve ça extraordinaire
en fait je comptais une domination une
domination qui n'en est pas une et qui
est fictive non gardé jalousement sa
jalousie il traduit plus une dépendance
qu'une véritable domination et vous
acceptez d'être objet parce que bon vous
l'acceptez pas comme un jeu actuellement
parce que vous n'avez jamais été jusque
là mais si vous ne deviez être
constamment je ne sais pas si vous ne
seriez pas j'ai plus beaucoup de temps
les docteurs vous avez dit tout à l'air
oui on remarque très pertinente
vous avez dit que je faisais moi de vous
dire dans le plumard sadc sont en-deça
l'homme reprenait le dessus
ben moi je suis pas d'accord je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que quand on se
rend compte avec une femme on se voit à
la verticale la femme pour être a
presque toujours à l'horizontale et
c'est risqué de rejouer l'espace est de
ce point dans la diagonale
si vous permettez j'aimerais avoir
l'avis de tirage
nous n'avons pas encore entendu alice de
la forme puisqu'ils leur destine à
longueur de jour non non non je ne suis
pas un spécialiste et la femme mais
quand on lui avait posé la question tout
à l'heure quelle est la femme idéale
pour vous j'ai pensé que je crois que
c'est pas de moi d'ailleurs que la femme
idéale c'est celle qui vous admirent le
plus
je crois c'est à dire sous une forme ou
sous une autre et vous admirez vous
trouver en elle tout ce que vous voulez
savoir sur vous maintenant moi je suis
un truc je suis
vous connaissez mes des sages fait des
petites femmes qui qui sont plutôt des
enfants mais au sens au sens pas d
enfant capricieux des enfants qui font
des dégâts
je veux dire que je sais que je cherche
ma femme c'est cette énergie qu'on les
enfants à aimer les choses à l'attention
qu'elle porte sur tel que voulait
figurer ce sont plutôt les femmes
d'idéaliser plate forme d'une heure moi
je fais des dessins pour faire rire les
gens
c'est pas du tout je trouve aussi des
petites salles au cargö ah oui ils sont
terrifiantes moi je vis toujours dans la
hantise de rencontrer ça un jour sans
très excitante
ah oui oui c'est pas décider de tout
repos qui rêvent d'en rabattre le
cinquième commandement de familiarité
coeur et alors c'est l'inversé là où je
réponds docteur parce que je les sais
bien tout ce qui vous il avait raison
des acteurs si nous avons parlé ce pas
de la femme quel besoin d'amis nationale
rien une autre qualité de la femme
formidable
c'est la femme qui a le sens de l'
esclavage cder et esclave de son époux
c'est le contrepoint la femme de la
fameuse dans la famille des à la femme
complète s'émerveiller aussi cette femme
là et en général sont les mêmes ce que
celle qui vous embête pour certaines
choses et qui ont l'air de porter la
culotte un moment si elles ont un homme
nous sommes tous des hommes monsieur
livraison maquis racisme des sommes
entre nous mais monsieur vous êtes jeune
déjà à nabeul et bien vous verrez ce
sont celles qui un môme sont les plus
esclave elle rampe devant will elles
sont admirables et ces femmes là c'est
une qualité
la femme qu'elle sort de l esclavage je
ne parle pas des femmes qui vont dans
les arrêts de jeu ne pousse pas jusque
là mais là toute femme a besoin d'être
esclave et nous rejoignons ce qu'a dit
qu'ils rasent c'est parce qu'elle a
besoin d'admirer l'homme est une fan des
monts sont que l'homme qu'elle admire la
femme qu admirer un homme et son esclave
et ça c'est une autre qualité de la
femme josé luis villalonga vous avez
connu d'un green oui je les connais
je tournais un film qui s'appelait
breakfast in tiffany avec pour de club
band et le tourner le dernier film ou
ajout est largué bonne il s'appelait le
misfits et ça c'est une femme qui est
aura un vrai mais c'est une coïncidence
que vous ayez montrer ça parce qu'elle
était détesté mais universellement par
tout le monde au studio c'était une
femme qui arrivait avec des heures de
retard qui laissait tout le monde en
plan clark gable était très très malade
à cette époque il avait eu des crises
cardiaques et il tourné ce film dans le
désert sous une chaleur torride et comme
un grand professionnel qu'il était il
arrivé à 8h du matin ils étaient là
maquiller prête à tourner et quelquefois
il attendu cette dame pendant des heures
et puis les morts à la fin du film
et naturellement les gens qui sont
toujours exagérées ont beaucoup beaucoup
attribué à marie line la mort prématurée
de si vous voulez l'ubs et c'était une
personne odieuse dans la vie éléments
tous le savent et d'ailleurs elle est
morte en ayant appelé plusieurs
personnes à vendre avant de mourir et
personne est allé même même pas voir si
c'était vrai ou pas tu n'étais pas aimé
du tout et c'est devenu le mythe de la
féminité la grâce de six comme quoi il
n'ya rien de nouveau que le cinéma est
ce que si à certains d'entre eux bouche
ce mot pour qui mens limbo représenter
la familiale n'ont pas dit mon sport
monsieur qui n'est pas du tout pas du
tout naïveté une certaine réalité chez
montrons que j'aime beaucoup et je
trouve que pour ceux ce côté là leur
semblent infimes bien évidemment pour
son côté mais est-ce que cela n'était
pas truqué
sinon pas connaître c'est pas méchant de
dire la vérité essentielle 6e conditions
pour la femme idéale dit qu'il allait
nous allons faire plaisir à beaucoup de
dames ce qu'on fait on dira que nous en
donnons des qualités qu'elle croit ne
pas avoir mais qu'elles sont il faut que
la famille des ailes je n'ai pas dit il
soit une bourgeoise mais de même que
j'ai dit faut qu'une femme idéale et le
sens de la domination le sens de l'éclat
esclavage
il faut qu'une familiale et le sens
bourg voit et ça le change bourgeois est
indispensable bon équilibre de la vie
d'un homme si cette femme est dans la
vie de cet homme et vous pouvez avoir
les femmes les plus les plus folles les
plus fantasques les plus fantaisistes
il ya la vie il ya 24 heures dans la
journée il y à quelques moments dans la
vie où il faut que cette femme ait un
équilibre pour voir si vous ne l'avez
pas c'est la pagaille ça ne peut pas
tenir ça ne peut pas marcher
est ce que c'est une qualité essentielle
de toutes les femmes depuis la vente
jusqu'a pauline carton vous comprenez
qu'il a eh bien il faut avoir cet
équilibre bourgeois pas trop pousser
mais il faut l'avouer super nes et votre
avis
oui je crois ce que vous pratiquez
couramment dans la vie d'un oui megan
qui conjugue halle qui est la mienne
exactement sans être un discours non
nous on va se pose pas la discrétion
mais ma femme bon ben reste au foyer
l affaire
[Musique]
ces différents petits travaux ménagers
peut-être un peu plus grand par jour
mais il arrive comme dit monsieur dsk
que j'arrive à la voir un brand content
la façon qu'a le gie la façon qu'a le
canard enchaîné chose
ce petit côté bourgeois qui ressort avec
un rien alors justement comme vous
disiez avec un dos rien du tout elle en
fait l'essai de l'emploi quelque chose
sur des touches exactement est-ce que
physiquement monsieur plenel
elle correspond à la fin vous aviez
envie d'épouser alors physiquement c'est
une femme parce que vous avez dit
absolument c'est sa femme qui donnerait
des crimes alors en ce qui concerne ma
femme physiquement non parce que je la
voyais enfin je les voyais pas parce que
je suis en effet un plan fort et honnête
mais en fait toujours avec l'arrière je
me suis tracé comme femme qui diane
physiquement une femme brûle ne ma femme
est blonde la grandeur n'en parlons pas
puisqu'à femmes de 70
mais ceci dit tout se passe très bien
les contrats non mais enfin mais le cerf
marqué à l'aller c'est très bien parce
que de faux nous avons quelques mots et
leur jette plus ou moins violemment mais
pour reprendre mais les conditions
qu'après cinq de guy des cars parce
qu'elle est plutôt dominatrix plutôt est
dominatrice mais assez mollement
justement c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est justement qu'on
voit un peut-être un peu l'expérience
dans ces messieurs c'est que c'est quand
on voit justement parce elle ses
claviers oui oui c'est rien a les traits
des mineurs est la mienne mais il arrive
des moments que effectivement et ce
qu'elle aime se complaire dans cet
esprit d esclavage ça reste pas
longtemps mais non pas ça vient comme ça
vient quand même dommage man meyers
était accusé d'y vivre entre la folie
comme ça quand même dans les qualités
qui a énuméré guider car on retrouve les
trois rôles les trois rôles essentiels
de la femme à savoir le rôle de vestale
du foyer vous la voulez bourgeoise
assurant à la fois la gastronomie
d'éducation les enfants vous la voulez
aussi grâce à la luxure vous la voulez
donc compagne de plaisir et même objet
sexuel
un esclave et si vous la voulez aussi
grâce à son ambition associés
professionnelle en fait effectivement ce
sont ces trois rôles qu'on demande à la
femme idéale et se sentent 1,62 gravité
qu'elle a souvent du mal à trouver elle
même et qui fait qu'elle ne correspond
pas toujours à ces normes que nous
projetons sur elle et que nous exigeons
d'elle facilement
gilbert je suis bien d'accord il ya une
qualité que je voudrais ajouter celles
dont on n'a pas parlé encore c'est la
femme maternelle pour moi la femme
idéale et maternelle naturellement et
par destination pour agir elle aime chez
les enfants la pureté la gaieté
l'innocence sans les adorer cette
évolution c'est peut être le summum de
difficultés ah oui j'ai gardé pour la
fin
coût d'un nous avons parlé tout à
l'heure de la beauté au début n'est ce
pas là toutes sortes de brut et on peut
être très belle âgée mais il y a une
qualité qui est certes edge et quel que
soit l'âge de la femme c'est sa jeunesse
n'est ce pas nous sommes une époque où
il ya beaucoup de vieux jeunes et de
jeunes vieux et des vieilles jeunes et
des jeunes vieilles vous avez des grands
mères vous avez des femmes formidables
qui sont jaloux
vous avez des filles de 20 ans qui sont
vieilles donc la jeunesse la jeunesse
intérieur intrinsèque de la femme est
une chose indispensable et ce qui est
grave quand je vois beaucoup
actuellement de deux réunions il ya des
jeunes femmes
je suis fasciné dans l'ensemble par leur
tristesse je suis fasciné par
l'expression d'ennui je ne dis pas pour
vous je suis sûr que la femme de vos
rêves et gay est jeune et qu'elle le
restera éternellement comme vous je suis
fasciné de voir des réunions de jeunes
j'ai un fils que j'aime beaucoup qui
voit des jeunes
ils ont tous les mois la mode des
problèmes ils ont tous un truc au poids
mais ils sont tristes
triste triste ce sont elles plus triste
que nous nous les sommes à dans
l'ensemble je crois que les femmes les
jeunes femmes sont plus tristes que les
hommes jeunes actuellement josé luis
duran
moi j'ai un fils qui à 27 ans qui de
temps en temps maintenant et d'amener à
la maison des jeunes filles en âge je
m'en vais toujours
et pourquoi parce que ces sinistres oui
parce que ces sinistres la jeunesse a
demandé à monsieur jean marc simon
la jeunesse principalement pour les
femmes s'en sont assez triste bon je
suis d'accord avec vous parce que je
constate moi également mais ne croyez
vous pas que la case jeunesse pour une
certaine conscience de la vie qu'elle
est bien réaliste et quels voisins qu'il
n'y a pas tellement de quoi rire avait
causé tout le monde applique aussi de la
vie à toutes les époques la demande d'un
ami veut me fait rigoler de conscience
de la vie à toutes les époques en
tombent actuellement les étudiants moi
ça me fait rigoler vous avez des
conditions de vie fabuleuse que nous
n'avons jamais connu jamais eu d'aidés
campus pour me balader les facultés
somptueuse on vivait ma des classes
épouvantable trois autres sujets le sait
ça croyez moi chaque époque
vous aurez des vieux jeunes et des
jeunes vieux nous revenons à la femme la
femme doit avoir au nail quelle qu'elle
soit qu'elles aient 18 ans qu'elle ait
30 ans qu'est les carottes dans 50 ou 90
ans elle doit voir la jeunesse lycée la
jeunesse du coeur et c'est là la
jeunesse du coeur à la dre également sur
son visage sur sa peau et si celle-ci la
passation savez ce qu'est né en suisse
où il a essentiellement l'accord la
jeunesse du coeur oui mais fera le
rayonnement de recife le rayonnement du
reste est à 60 ans ils méritent la même
tendresse cavens exactement je cale et
c'est là c'est la joie de vivre en fait
oui qu'elle sait faire partager
voilà une femme pour moi la femme idéale
c'est d'abord une femme heureuse
une femme qui sait vivre une femme qui
est jeune qui qui profite de la vie
pleinement et qui sait partager avec les
siens avec son mari avec ses enfants
cet art parce qu'en fait comme vous
dites il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
actuellement triste je vais me faire
leur avocat vous savez j'ai l'impression
que c'est tous extrêmement exigeants
vis-à-vis c'est pas toutes les qualités
qu'on demande aux femmes assument adomos
pardon je ne pense pas qu'on soit
exigeant si vous faisiez le résumé de
tout ce qu'on vient de dire et de
discuter pendant des heures d'une façon
très littéraire est remarquable par les
chutes et qu'un plus simple par monsieur
mais d'une spontanéité beaucoup plus si
day idéalisé 1 par monsieur d'un
réalisme absolu et successifs un épisode
comme la vie de monsieur villalonga dans
le fond je crois qu'on peut résumer tout
par une phrase la famille d'air à
l'autre c'est purement et simplement
celle qui nous rendent
cette chance et ça c'est à dire pour la
trouve finalement toujours c'est la
somme qu'on découvrira que nous la
question je pense pas la question n'est
pas là d'ailleurs elle ne peut pas je ne
pense pas qu'une femme puisse rester
idéal d'abord parce qu'il faudrait
qu'elles aient toutes les qualités et
tout les défauts non ce que je crois si
vous voulez vous donner vous permettre
de vous donner mon opinion je vous en je
crois qu'il ya des questions de passe et
qui sont les suivants dresse à ce que
j'appellerais si vous voulez le
principal le superflu en ce qui concerne
les défauts et les qualités il faut
qu'ils aient complémentarité est par
contre en ski et les goûts il faut là au
contraire qu' ils soient les mêmes je
m'explique avait 2-3 exemple c'est très
simple prenons je venais pas je vais me
citer mon cas personnel je peux t'on à
tempérament artiste de toi que je serai
enthousiasme et une semaine calme
l'autre
eh bien j'ai ma femme moi je suis né
scorpions ma femme est née balance c'est
la continuité dans les farces état
régulateur et j'avoue que si les x
allemand qui mais n'est ce pas elle a
été la femme idéale en ce sens qu'elle
voulait voir dans même elle l a poussé à
cette régularisation dont j'avais besoin
par contre en ce qui est si vous voulez
le plaisir moi qu'est ce qu'on voudrait
c'est le contraire moi j'étais sa une au
bord de la mer j'ai toujours fait du
bateau
ma femme rien que de voir abattoirs lama
le coeur bat il avait inséré
à ce moment là je voulais dire que a
toutes les qualités qu'on demande à la
femme idéale combien d'entre nous
pourrions nous prêtons date le prétendre
à être l'homme idéal aussi c'est une
autre édition ça c'est une autre
émission au fil des mois jeu mais je
voudrais dire alors je complète parce
que moi je vais vous donner quand même
ma définition de la femme idéale pour
moi je crois que la femme idéale si elle
est tellement variables dans le temps
dans l'espace et dans notre vie car nous
avons vous l'avez dit vous-même vous
avez vous avez eu peut-être vous avez
suivi toujours le même prototype mais
avec des nuances avec des changements
il serait d'ailleurs il serait très
intéressant de voir quelle est notre
mécanisme de répétition en vis-à-vis des
différentes femmes que nous connaissons
eh bien je crois que la femme idéale
c'est celle qui finalement à une époque
de notre vie nous permet de vivre
véritablement nos fantasmes c'est à dire
nos sensations profonde ins et celle qui
va les réaliser n'est ce pas et c'est
pour ça qu'elle est tellement valable
alors bien sûr on peut penser avec
monsieur par exemple est très souvent
rationalise cet accord cesser ses
affinités en dix ans nous avons les
mêmes goûts nous jouons tous les deux au
tennis nous ont tous les deux au bridge
où elle me sécurise mais en fait en fait
le véritable problème très souvent c'est
que ce sont des fantasmes c'est des
impressions très ancienne des
impressions infantile qui sont qui sont
vécues grâce à cette femme est très
souvent vous croyez mais cette femme par
ce cas là telle ou telle ou telle
qualité que vous lui trouvez et voulait
mais parce que vous retrouvez en elle un
parfum que vous avez connu exactement
comme avec sa matière par exemple jouer
il faut terminer juste un dernier mot je
crois que la femme idéale
il faut la fuir comme la peste j'en suis
la personne la femme idéale c'est le
c'est le but à accomplir alors le jour
que vous avez trouver ce que vous
cherchez
et qu'il est là c'est l'ennui c'est
l'horreur c'est l'angoissé la femme
idéale il faut la trouver la chercher là
se trompent et recommencer enfin mais la
famille zen - la femme idéale vous
permet de vivre une passion oui pour
vraiment vivre avec quelqu'un il faut
accepter ses limites et accepter ses
défauts je crois que nous allons nous
allons rester là monsieur je vous
connais excusé devant rester là nous
étions onze sur l'autre plateau mais la
bombe aux hommes / dans un jour dit
nadal nous avons essayé de vous définir
tels que nous voyons idéalement et nous
allons le quitter ici pour cette année
c'est ce bouquet en quelque sorte sera
l'hommage toujours en haut et peut-être
comme les épater son début de cette
édition
serez vous l'année prochaine en 1974
cette femme encore plus proche de celle
que nous souhaitons en tout cas nous
quittons aujourd'hui ne lui qu'ils
tournent maintenant pour cette année
1973 nous vous présentons nos voeux les
meilleurs et les plus sincères sur la
formule consacrée
et pour nous quitter on immerge nous
allons garder quelqu'un dont on va
parler encore mais qui assez souvent
représenté ce qui peut être assez près
de la femme idéale c'est brigitte bardot
tout simplement dans et dieu créa la
femme
au revoir
[Musique]